do you regret some of the mockery
uh and the snarky use on Twitter and
even in your show that kind of feeds
that Division I don't regret it in the
sense that it's a calculated part or
tool
that I use in addition to figuring out
how to simplify complicated Concepts and
choosing stories that I think are
underrepresented and you know it's it's
all part of like the package of what I'm
doing I recognize that my show is not
the audio visual visual version of a
peer-reviewed uh you know randomized
controlled trial about abortion views on
abortion or whatever the case like I'm
very much aware of that but I don't
regret including it as a as a tool that
I've used to build the community in some
total that I've built over the last more
than 10 years I guess I could ask about
the different trajectories you think
your show might take so
you know the dynamic you had with Donald
Trump Jr and maybe Candace Owens is the
more appropriate comparison
are you okay having that dance
for the next few years between you and
Candace Owens and just kind of the
mockery the derision that's a part of
that process and and taking part in that
you know I'm fine with it
in the sense of personally
I tolerate it well
until it crosses the line
and people pull my family in and people
right so that's the part that we set the
family stuff aside if I set that aside
just in the digital space I'm glad to
mix it up now the truth is Candace Owens
has had me blocked for years up until
this incident
she unblocked me just to tweet about
what I tweeted about I don't know the
backstory of that genuinely I have no
idea so I don't have a sense that she's
super interested in engaging with me on
that but all of these people I mean
Candace Owens is welcome on my show
anytime Don Jr's welcome on my show
anytime it's been a decade since I had
Ben Shapiro on he's welcome at any time
I'm glad to have these conversations and
I think it's an important thing and also
I wish that everybody was willing to
have the conversations in good faith
rather than his performance uh it's not
even really performance art rather than
being simply performative for an
audience that you have